[Music]  oh boy there he is  what's up my man come give me hug  [Music]  I really can almost wear a suit exactly  like that  we're are strange strangely like  brothers I don't have a lot of clothes  men friend my round table so this week  this is teh I don't even have a table  but Charlie and I always cook food for  each other we met on sons of anarchy  Manson came in what's up dudes  Manson came in and didn't have a couple  episodes maybe like five or six and we  just became pals so off the idea of you  guys's friends I know we're an unlikely  duo but we love each other is it about  you guys that you get on so well he's  more handsome than me  you gotta be talking about me yeah of  course  okay so I could have the most handsome  or in the world